Der FC führt weiter die Tabelle an, der HSV und Kaiserslautern sind ihm aber dicht auf den Fersen. Die zweite Bundesliga, der Männer, sie hält uns weiterhin auf Trab und darüber spreche ich jetzt mit Nils Baumhoff von den Rocket Beans und Sebastian Zovell vom SWR. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Langeheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, wäre lang genug für Gilly Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ja Leute, was soll ich sagen? Ich muss mich hier schon wieder entschuldigen. Solltet ihr letzte Woche alle den Podcatcher eures Vertrauens wie wild aktualisiert haben und keine neue Ligaturfolge zur zweiten Liga gefunden haben, dann war das kein Fehler bei euch, sondern ja eine Abfolge unglücklicher Ereignisse, was auch dazu führt, dass ich hier jetzt sitze und nicht mag. Ich bin Eva-Lotta Bohle und ich habe trotz mehr Personaldrama in den letzten sieben Tagen als bei Kaiserslautern und dem ASV zusammen die Ehre, heute über die zweite Bundesliga der Männer zu sprechen. Und bevor ich euch die beiden Menschen vorstelle, die das gleich mit mir machen, wie immer der Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch Euro-Spenden, also werdet gerne Rasenfunk-Supporter innen, falls ihr das noch nicht seid. Den Link dafür findet ihr auch in den Show-Notes. Jetzt darf ich euch aber die beiden Gäste vorstellen und wir fangen an zum, ich glaube es ist eine Rasenfunk-Premiere, korrigiere mich, wenn ich da falsch liege, aber du bist sicherlich schon vielen bekannt, vor allem wenn sie Bundesliga hören. Hallo Nils, schön, dass du beim Rasenfunk dabei bist.
Ja, da bin ich auch, ich fand den Kader von Kaiserslautern auch spannend, weil ich irgendwie so dachte, ja was hat sich denn da so viel getan? Und ich fand irgendwie auch spannend, dass man irgendwie ein bisschen vergisst, dass man unter anderem ja auch Tomiak abgegeben hat an Hannover, wenn ich das jetzt nicht falsch... Aber so, man erstmal, also erstmal dachte so, das könnte jetzt irgendwie ja doch irgendwie nochmal entscheidend sein, einfach weil das jetzt schon irgendwie so ein Name ist, den man irgendwie immer kannte. Also es ist ja durchaus ein erfahrener Spieler auch irgendwie, aber mehr hat man bisher auf jeden Fall wenig von. Aber lass uns doch jetzt tatsächlich einmal auf den Trainer schauen, beziehungsweise willst du erst noch was anderes sagen, bevor ich dich...
Nee, ich wollte eigentlich nur sagen, dass es bei Boris Tomiak ähnlich war wie bei Sirch. Defensiver Spieler, aber auch mit ordentlich Zug zum Tor, der hat zum Beispiel auch die Elfmeter immer geschossen beim FCK. Und von daher war man da schon am Anfang so, okay krass, wenn der jetzt geht, ob der eine große Lücke hinterlässt, aber es denkt jetzt keiner mehr an Boris Tomiak, bei allem Respekt vor Boris Tomiak, der ein super Kicker ist, aber die Lücke, die da entstanden ist, hat man nie wirklich gesehen auf dem Platz.
Ja, aber dann lass uns einmal tatsächlich auf Markus Anfang blicken. Also er hat ja im Sommer übernommen, nachdem man ja, man hat ja ganz kurz Recap, letzte Saison ist Dirk Schuster als Trainer, hat ihn dann entlassen, hat dann mit Friedhelm Funkel zu Ende gemacht. Und jetzt eben Markus Anfang. Wie, also ich glaube so ganz einfach, weil die Personalie Markus Anfang ja immer so ein bisschen diskutiert ist sowieso, dann kam er ja von der Zeit bei Dynamo Dresden, wo er ja zweimal hintereinander den Ausstieg verpasst hat von der dritten, von der dritten in die zweite Liga. Was war denn eigentlich dein erster Gedanke damals, als es dann hieß Markus Anfang, der wird's jetzt?
Tatsächlich war der erste Gedanke, puh könnte schwierig werden. Aber so ging es einfach vielen, weil man sagen muss, dass natürlich die Personalien Markus Anfang in diesem Fußball-Zirkus, ja natürlich einfach so durch diese Impfpass-Geschichte sehr negativ behaftet war, teilweise auch immer noch ist. Und natürlich hatte ich, wie viele andere auch, einfach ziemlich große Vorbehalte, ob das funktionieren kann. Weil ich das immer auch schwierig finde, jetzt ganz unabhängig davon, warum dieser Mensch so im Fokus steht, wenn dieser Fokus so sehr auf dieser Person ist. Egal ob jetzt im positiven oder negativen Sinne, natürlich brauchst du, und natürlich ist es immer so, wenn du große Trainernamen hast, die polarisieren. Ist ja vollkommen klar. Aber gerade bei einem Club wie Lautern ist es dann so, wenn dann so jemand kommt. Ja, also da gab es einfach super viele Vorbehalte, ob das funktionieren kann. Aber ich glaube, Markus Anfang hat es mittlerweile oder nicht, ich glaube, sondern es ist Fakt. Man sieht es, man merkt es im Umfeld, hat es geschafft, die Leute von seiner Arbeit zu überzeugen, hat es geschafft, der Mannschaft seine eigene Handschrift zu geben. Und ja, was soll man sagen? Der Erfolg gibt ihm natürlich recht. Also es ist ja bei vielen Leuten, mir geht es ja ähnlich wie Nils. Hättest du mich vor der Saison gefragt, hätte ich auch nicht gesagt, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass der FCK eine Rolle im oberen Drittel spielt. Oder im oberen Drittel vielleicht schon, aber dass der FCK ein Wörtchen um die Aufstiegspätze mitredet, hätte ich niemals gedacht. Klar, wir haben es gerade eben schon gesagt, wir müssen abwarten, wie es sich entwickelt, ob sie sich dauerhaft da oben festsetzen können. Aber der Erfolg gibt ihm recht und mittlerweile weiß ich nicht, wie lange ich jetzt schon nichts mehr negatives in Sachen Markus Anfang gehört habe.
Kann ich was zu sagen?
Natürlich.
Ja, weil ich habe ein ziemlich teures Szenario, weil Markus Anfang ist verantwortlich dafür, dass Werder Bremen damals aufgestiegen ist und nicht der HSV, weil das dann mit dem Trainerwechsel auf Werner bei Werder wieder bergauf ging. Und wenn ihr jetzt mit Anfang aufsteigt und der HSV dann vielleicht nur dritter wird oder so, dann ist er für den zweiten nicht aufstiegsverantwortlich.
Ja, das haben wir auch extra, das haben die Verantwortlichen extra so geplant. Das ist der Plan, wie man den HSV hinter sich lässt.
Das ist mein Gefühl, dass da was dran ist.
Aber man muss ja dazu sagen, also ich finde halt so interessant, weil jetzt mal abgesehen von der Personalien Markus Anfang im öffentlichen Sinne, Markus Anfang auf sportlicher Ebene, also er kommt halt dahingehend aus diesen zwei Dresden-Jahren natürlich auch nicht ganz unbelastet raus. Von daher, also und ich meine auch da war, also wir sprechen nicht von Dynamo, ist kachend am Aufstieg gescheitert, sondern Dynamo Dresden war gefühlt bis fünf Tage vor Schluss im Aufstiegsrennen dabei und ist dann gescheitert. Sie haben quasi den HSV gepole, nur in der dritten Liga. Entschuldige, da ist nichts. Bin gewohnt. Also deshalb war es für mich tatsächlich eine überraschende Personalien, weil ich gedacht habe, naja, er kommt jetzt einfach nicht mit der besten Vita, einfach von seinen Nicht-Erfolgen zuletzt. Und das war bei mir so im Hintergrund.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber da muss ich schon auch sagen, natürlich hat es dann bei Dresden knapp nicht gereicht, aber streckenweise oder über lange Strecken hat es ja ganz gut funktioniert und hat die Mannschaft auch ganz gut performt in Dresden unter Markus Anfang. Von daher, aber die Frage ist ja auch immer, und das auch jetzt bei allem Respekt vor Markus Anfang, vor seinem Namen, vor seiner Arbeit, aber was hat man denn für Ansprüche in Kaiserslautern, wen man auch im Hinblick darauf, wie es in den vergangenen Jahren gelaufen ist, wem man da als Trainer präsentieren kann. Da war es auch so, das war nicht nur, dass die Leute gesagt haben, oh Mensch, Markus Anfang, heißes Eisen mit seiner Geschichte da, aber da war es auch so, Markus Anfang, wir brauchen doch hier, wir brauchen einen anderen Namen, wir brauchen jemanden mit mehr Standing und kann noch nicht sein, aber ja. Also da muss man sich, das ist das, was ich auch, das sage ich bei uns im Podcast ganz oft, das sage ich hier jetzt auch, das sage ich in meinem privaten Umfeld ganz oft. Man muss diesen berühmten Schritt zurück ganz oft mal machen und mal gucken, wo kommen wir denn überhaupt her? Natürlich ist der FCK, wie es Nils auch schon gesagt hat, ein großer Name, viel Tradition und so weiter und so fort. Davon kannst du dir aber nichts kaufen. Du kannst dir nichts davon kaufen, dass du 98 als Aufsteiger deutscher Meister warst. Du kannst dir jetzt auch nicht viel davon kaufen, dass du vergangenes Jahr im Pokalfinale warst, auch wenn das super, super wichtig war, auch für den Zusammenhalt mit den Fans und für die ganze Euphorie, die da jetzt insgesamt entstanden ist. Aber man muss sich bewusst machen, wo kommt der FCK her? Der FCK kommt aus super bitteren Drittliga-Jahren. Der FCK wäre fast von der Bildfläche erst mal für längere Zeit verschwunden. Also auch finanziell. Viel ist einfach schlecht gelaufen in den vergangenen Jahren. Also wer ist der FCK oder wer sind die Leute, dass sie sagen, wir hätten jetzt hier, was weiß ich, hätten wir nicht mal bei Pep Guardiola oder so anfangen, wenn ich jetzt übertrieben gesagt hätte. Aber von daher, klar hat es vielleicht viele gewundert, aber ich glaube, mittlerweile sieht man, dass es relativ gut matcht. Jetzt muss man sehen, wie nachhaltig ist das Ganze. Es wäre generell auch mal schön, wenn beim FCK mal wieder ein Trainer für längere Zeit einfach die Chance hätte, was zu entwickeln, weil davon redet man beim FCK auch schon seit Jahren. Man redet davon, es muss nachhaltig was entwickelt werden. Und was mich da auch immer so ein bisschen fuchst, ist diese Tatsache, wenn du davon sprichst, was zu entwickeln, dann musst du ja eigentlich als Verein, als Vereinsführung eine gewisse Spielidee haben und sagen, ich richte mich danach aus, das gebe ich vor und dementsprechend holen wir Personal, holen wir Trainer, die so spielen. Wenn du aber mal guckst, wen du in den vergangenen Jahren beim FCK als Trainer hattest von Marco Antwerpen über Friedhelm Funkel, über Demetrius Gramozis, jetzt Marco Antwerpen, das sind ja völlig unterschiedliche Trainertypen. Von daher wäre es jetzt auch mal an der Zeit und eigentlich ganz nett, wenn mal jemand über längere Zeit die Chance bekommt, da was zu entwickeln, weil ich glaube einfach dieser Verein, diese Region, das wird ja auch immer sehr, sehr häufig zitiert und auch kritisiert, dass da von der Region gesprochen wird. Aber das hat so viel Potenzial und da musst du jetzt mal jemandem die Chance geben, das über längere Zeit wieder zu wecken und aufzubauen. Von daher, ja, also ich glaube, it's a match mit Markus Anfang.
Wie siehst du das dann finanziell? Also wie sagst du denn, braucht der FCK auch mal wieder ein Bundesliga-Jahr aus finanziellen Gründen oder sagst du okay, wenn du jetzt irgendwie in diesen einfach diese Drittliga-Jahre erstmal hinter dir lässt, in dieser Fünf-Jahres-Wertung eben einfach auch das rein finanziell zwei, drei Jahre, zweite Liga auch vollkommen in Ordnung wären?
Der FCK braucht definitiv wieder mehr Einnahmen. Dem FCK würde es vor allem gut tun, sich jetzt mal unabhängig vom Aufstieg, sich über längere Zeit auch mal in einem hohen einstelligen Tabellenplatz, auch in der zweiten Liga einfach zu etablieren, dass du in der TV-Geld-Tabelle einfach kontinuierlich weiter nach oben kommst, weil da merkst du einfach, dass immer wieder bei dem Thema, wo kommst du her aus Drittliga-Zeiten? Es dauert einfach super lange und du musst super lange wieder relativ erfolgreich sein, bis du auf einem einigermaßen vernünftigen Level bist, weil du hinkst einfach den Mannschaften, die in der Zeit, wo du dritte Liga gespielt hast, zweite Liga gespielt haben, du hinkst denen super hinterher. Von der Bundesliga muss man gar nicht sprechen. Thomas Hengen hat da auch als Beispiel Heidenheim angeführt, die einfach über super lange Zeit kontinuierlich in der zweiten Liga einen guten Job gemacht haben, relativ weit oben mitgespielt haben, dadurch hohe Einnahmen generiert haben durch die TV-Gelder und mittlerweile dann den Sprung nach oben geschafft haben. Von daher ja, der FCK braucht das definitiv, dass das einfach wieder ein bisschen mehr möglich ist. Was natürlich super geholfen hat, war natürlich der Pokal. Also diese Pokalsaison, das sind natürlich die besten Einnahmen, die du haben kannst, Einnahmen, mit denen du nicht rechnest, die du nicht einkalkuliert hast und die dann quasi überraschend kommen. Plus natürlich alles das, was damit einhergeht, dass du einfach wieder so ein kleines Ausrufezeichen auf der Landkarte gesetzt hast und gesagt hast, hey, hallo, wir sind immer noch da, uns gibt es immer noch, hi FCK, wir waren lange nicht da, jetzt sind wir wieder da. Yes, you're back. Genau.
Ja, also ich bin jetzt wirklich sehr gespannt, was zumindest nach den nächsten zwei, aber vielleicht auch sogar nach den nächsten drei Spielen passiert, weil du hast eben jetzt Hannover HSV als die nächsten beiden Gegner zu Hause gegen Hannover aus jetzt beim HSV. Und dann hast du zu Hause noch mal gegen Regensburg. Also eigentlich dann noch mal so ein Gegner, der rein vom Tabellenplatz eigentlich in die diese Gegner rund um Münster und Ulm einpasst. Von daher wird das da natürlich auch spannend sein, wie kriegst du da wieder den Switch in? Also zwischen diesen Hoch- und Runterspielen quasi.
Das war in der Hinrunde eins der miesesten Spiele, ein 0 zu 0 in Regensburg. Also das sind unangenehme Gegner, auch wenn die jetzt natürlich irgendwie abgeschlagen da unten am Tabellenende stehen. Aber die musst du auch erstmal schlagen. Und ich glaube, da hatte HSV in der Vergangenheit auch so ein paar Erlebnisse mit solchen Teams gemacht.
Also was du schon gesagt hast, das waren nicht nur Aufsteiger. Es waren beim HSV sogar, wenn das Stadion weniger als 20.000 Leute fasst, hat der HSV glaube ich noch nie in der zweiten Liga gewonnen.
Krank. So Elbersberg und sowas.
Ja, also das ist genau diese Atmosphäre, die ist ja überall gleich eng, meistens schlechter Rasen. Es wird gekämpft, es wird gerackert, es gibt Standardsituationen und so. Und so einen Gegner zu bespielen, erfordert auch ein ganz anderes Mindset, eine ganz andere taktische Herangehensweise als jetzt ein Duell gegen die Großen. Und du hast halt natürlich in dieser Liga sehr viele Vereine, die Ambition haben, weshalb sie gegen eine Mannschaft wie Kaiserslautern auch mitspielen und sagen, ich will das Spiel gewinnen. Das ist halt was anderes, als wenn du Geregensburg, Münster, Ulm, Braunschweig bespielst, die vielleicht sagen, ne macht ihr mal und dann ist Kaiserslautern eben auch als Spitzenteam dann gefordert, Lösungen zu finden gegen solche Mannschaften.
Aber hat der Asphal nicht schon mal gegen Paraborn gewonnen? In Paraborn? Sicherlich.
Also die Statistik habe ich nur gelesen und nicht selber recherchiert. Von daher kann es natürlich auch absoluter Quatsch sein. Aber jetzt ist es draußen in der Welt, andere Leute werden es reproduzieren und irgendwann wird es zur Wahrheit.
Ne, aber ich könnte es tatsächlich so auch nicht sagen. Ich habe auch vielleicht auch einfach so Gedächtnis, Evidenz. Aber ich bin tatsächlich sehr gespannt, was da eben auch rauskommt bei beiden Vereinen, ehrlich gesagt. Also eben beim HSV und bei Kaiserslautern. Ich sage es ganz ehrlich, ich würde es vor allem dem HSV jetzt auch einfach mal gönnen. Erstens, ich habe auch einfach keine Lust mehr auf diese Witze. Es ist einfach sämtliche Medienabteilungen lachen sich jedes Jahr im Frühjahr irgendwie ein ab und ich finde es einfach nur noch nervig.
Von daher können wir sagen, das ist Mobbing, das ist so ein Bulliverhalten. Na ist doch so, wir kennen alle so Leute in der Schule, das ist wenn das Opfer eh schon im Spind eingesperrt wird, dann kommen die Witze raus. Und das ist Bulli, ich notiere mir das, ich höre ganz kurz an die lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen, ich notiere mir das seit Jahren. Ich weiß genau, wer hier welche Sprüche bringt und irgendwann kommt Redemption Day.
Ja, also als Fan und ja, nicht nur Fan, sondern auch Bewohnerin der Stadt Bielefeld, ja, weiß ich alles zu Witzen und dass man sie einfach nicht mehr hören kann.
Aber wo wohnst du wirklich, weil Bielefeld gibt es ja nicht.
Genau, also es kann auch wirklich, ich glaube, ihr könnt ihr einfach mal eine Bombe hochgehen und der erste Kommentar bei Instagram, mir hör mal Bielefeld gibt es doch gar nicht. Von daher, ich fühle das sehr. Vielleicht habe ich deshalb auch ein bisschen Mitleid, weil man es einfach nicht mehr hören kann. Aber ich würde sagen, wir sind am Ende dieser Folge angelangt. Ich hätte mit euch beiden 100 prozentig schon eine Stunde mehr reden können, weil es eigentlich nur so viele Themen gibt, die wir jetzt nicht abgearbeitet haben. Aber ihr müsst ja einfach nochmal wiederkommen. So einfach ist das. Ein bisschen dauert die Saison ja noch. Deshalb danke ich als allererstes Nils Bommer für seine Premiere im Rasenfunk, dass du dich erfolgreich eingeklagt hast.
Ja, danke nochmal an meinen Anwalt und herzlichen Dank fürs Einknicken und die Einladung.
Und vielen Dank auch an Sebastian. Schön, dass du auch hier, muss man ja auch sagen, eingesprungen bist quasi durch diverse andere Gegebenheiten hier. Also Sebastian, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mal wieder was zum FCK erzählt hast.
Ich finde es super, dass du nochmal deutlich gemacht hast den Leuten, dass ich eigentlich nur die zweite oder dritte Wahl war, aber es ist überhaupt kein Problem. Ich komme auch als zweite oder dritte Wahl immer sehr gerne, gar kein Thema.
Sie ist wie Polzin.
Ja, sie ist wie Polzin.
Oder wie der FCK im Ausstiegsrennen.
Und nächste Woche bin ich in Hamburg vor Ort beim Spiel gegen den HSV, von daher Nils, ich würde dem HSV auf jeden Fall auch irgendwann den Aufstieg gönnen. Habe ich sehr große Sympathie für diese Stadt auch, weil ich da selber auch mal eine Zeit lang gewohnt hab. Von daher, ja, aber an diesen Spieltag.
Da nicht gerade da aufsteigen.
Nee.
Ich glaube, das wird auch schwierig. Ich bedanke mich auch bei allen Zuhörenden. Es geht dann nächste Woche. Hoffentlich. Vielleicht sollte er einfach solche Prognosen lassen. Hoffentlich nächste Woche hier tatsächlich schon wieder mit Marc weiter. Freut euch drauf und freut euch auf ein Wochenende. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.